j'aimerais avoir le témoignage de la vie
de thabo afs qui étaient sur les lieux
vous étiez là bas donc samedi soir et
vous étiez là bas vendredi soir c'est ça
hein t'as samedi soir et dimanche soir
voilà ben bon sang versé pour
l'invitation bâtir et moi j'aimerais
commencer à partir que ba cette
situation - une touche déjà
particulièrement parce que je suis issu
des quartiers populaires c'est une
affaire qui est dramatique
quarante personnes en vérité elle
aggrave même la situation qui est déjà
extrêmement compliqué en banlieue alors
d'une crise s'animer cet incident n'a
pas besoin de ça on n'a pas besoin
exactement exactions et mais le truc
c'est que les premières victimes de
cette situation c'est succès des
habitants des quartiers populaires
et si aujourd'hui certains d'entre eux
sont sortis hier soir dans plusieurs
villes en france
crier leur colère c'est pas uniquement
le fait de la sphère de villeneuve la
garenne je pense qu'on en a marre on en
a parlé
guy à donner le témoignage j'ai été son
casier j'ai aussi pris des témoignages
qui correspondait exactement à ce qu'a
dit guy au fait que moi j'étais surface
j'ai vu la voix j'ai vu la voix de
delarue qui est très très étroite
les policiers dans la dans la version de
la police ont dit qu'ils savaient qu'il
y avait une moto des rares qui arrivait
à plus de vitesse
il y avait aucun aucune qu'on apprécie
sa responsabilité pour les policiers
aucun aucun justificatif d'ouvrir la
portière parce qu'à partir du moment où
tu ouvriras partir tu laissais aucun
passage à la moto aucun quand tu vois là
quand tu vois la rue comment il est
quand tu vois les traces de freinage
très très très tardivement à côté du feu
rouge
tu sais que la particule que le mec a
été surpris par l'ouverture des
portières qui n'a pas voulu leur foncer
dessus à part si c'était un kamikaze ça
est une donnée canapa mais pour revenir
plus globalement sur ce qui s'est passé
les amarres voilà c'est pas uniquement
donc le fait de la sphère de villeneuve
la garenne c'est une accumulation
d'injustice de violences notamment
policières bon depuis des années déjà
mais aussi pendant ce confinement
il ya énormément de cas à grigny à torcy
aux ulis à aubervilliers aulnay la
courneuve
les lilas à toulouse marseille béziers
mais qui est moral in and en partie et
bien sûr qu'il faut appeler à respecter
les mesures de confinement même si c'est
très dur est beaucoup plus dur dans les
quartiers avec la promiscuité
l'insalubrité etc
mais moi ce qui me met en colère c'est
quand on pointe du doigt les jeunes de
banlieue en expliquant que ce sont eux
spécifiquement qui ne respectent pas le
confinement
moi je suis amené à sortir tous les
jours en tant que journaliste à faire
des reportages et je peux vous garantir
que le relâchement
il concerne toute la population quand tu
vois des mecs dans les parcs se balader
avec leurs vélos leur machart dans les
beaux quartiers
c'est tout le monde est le truc c'est
tient tout un tas de facteurs
économiques et sociaux la promiscuité la
précarité donkey et aggrave la situation
avec l'épidémie du co lead c'est un taux
de mortalité qui est plus élevé
qu'ailleurs dans les quartiers un
directeur général de la santé notamment
qui parle d'un niveau exceptionnel en
seine-saint-denis mais assurez notamment
c'est parce que les gens ils continuent
à bosser et qui n'ont pas la chance de
télétravail et ses 5 ans je vous ai
quand j'ai essayé quand ajouté et quand
je parle de colère de ces jeunes à ces
jeunes là tu vois leur maman leur papa
qui se met en danger qui vont au charbon
il son caissier ils sont postiers ils
sont conducteurs de bus y aura des
libéraux et c'est eux qui portent la
société à bout de bras aujourd'hui
parallèlement à ça parallèlement à ça
c'est eux qui sont montrés du doigt
comme ce qui mettrait en danger la
société